wearing black uniforms versus the San
Francisco warriors estill Trek so as
long as basketball has been popular way
before dunking was a thing
basketball was dominated by the
acrobatics empowering players who could
bring the ball to the basket with a leap
and a stretch back then there was no
such thing as a pre pointer players
would swarm under the basket scrambling
for two-point shots but in the late 70s
the three-point line was officially
adopted in pro ball as a way to push
players away from the basket the line
was marked out 23 feet 9 inches from the
arc of the line and 22 feet from the
corners it spread the players out and
made the game less of a scrap but for
decades the slam dunk reigned as the
number one crowd-pleaser not anymore
the three-pointer is the game's new star
as basketball tactics become more
technical and data-driven players like
steph curry are making three-pointers
their stock-in-trade
the game is beginning to look very
different not everyone likes it
critics like the coach of the San
Antonio Spurs argue it's ruining the
beauty of the two-point game
others like Mark Cuban owner of the
Dallas Mavericks
want the three-point line to be moved
back a few feet sound crazy it actually
wouldn't be the first time the NBA has
moved the three-point line in the 90s
while dunking legends like Michael
Jordan dominated the round ball the
league moved the line in from 23 feet 9
inches to a uniform 22 feet
three-pointers spiked by 66 percent in
that first year so the league moved the
line back to its original dimensions at
the end of 1997 going further out
wouldn't be easy even an increase to say
25 feet would require the league to
increase the size of its courts don't
bet on that happening instead the game
will probably change adapting to the
threat of three-point tactics so
basketball fans better get used to the
sound of that sweet outside swish